bonjour à toutes et à tous j'espère que
vous êtes en forme parce qu'aujourd'hui
je vous emmène à la montagne non non je
ne vous fais pas marché on va vraiment
faire de la randonnée au va grimper tout
là-haut au col de coûts juste le temps
de remplir ma gourde
à travers et on part à la rencontre des
marines on va les observer sans les
déranger mais avant de partir une petite
vérification pour par marcher en
montagne il faut prendre un coupe vent
ou un vêtement de pluie à la montagne le
temps change très vite une trousse
premiers secours pour soigner les petits
bobos de la crème solaire carlao ça tape
très fort de quoi refaire le plein
d'énergie des barres de céréales ou des
fruits secs une lampe de poche car on
peut être surpris par la nuit et enfin
de locaux au moins un litre par personne
voilà vous êtes prêts alors c'est parti
[Musique]
ce qui est bien à la montagne c'est
quand grimpant on croise des espèces
qu'on ne rencontre pas ailleurs et
végétaux et des animaux qui sont
capables de résister à l'altitude
bonjour
bonjour et également aux écarts de
températures froides hiver chaud l'été
on appelle ça l'amplitude thermique et
les rois de ce paysage et sont autour de
moi ce sont les sapins mais aussi les
épiques mais à quand celui ci autrement
dit des conifères
[Musique]
qui en fait vous savez pourquoi on les a
baptisés conifères c'est à cause de
leurs fruits en forme de cône comme la
fameuse pomme de pain en a plein autour
de moi on dit aussi très souvent
résineux je vous montrais pourquoi
quand un conifère est blessé comme ici
il sécrète une sorte de liquide visqueux
poisseux attention ce n'est pas de la
scène c'est la fameuse résine une
substance qui va protéger l'arbre contre
les parasites les mauvaises bactéries et
les champignons
ça colle au noir bas
l'autre caractéristique des conifères ce
sont leurs feuilles ou plutôt leurs
aiguilles elle se renouvelle en
permanence ce qui permet à l'arbre de
rester vert pendant toute l'année y
compris pendant l'hiver et grâce à ses
aiguilles l'arbre peut également
résister au froid et au gel on va faire
une petite expérience
en fait les feuillus comme c'est érable
perdent leurs feuilles en automne pour
éviter de trop grandes pertes d'eau en
transpirant pendant l'hiver de l'eau
qu'il ne pourrait pas renouveler étant
donné qu'en hiver le sol est très
souvent gelés j'ai bien dit que l'arbre
transpirait il respire est il trop spire
et vous pouvez le constater chez vous ou
à l'école en faisant cette petite
expérience
il ya une petite demi heure j'ai
emmailloté cette branche dans un sac en
plastique que j'ai refermer
hermétiquement et regardez bien ce qui
se passe maintenant
le sac est plein de but et il ya même
des petites gouttelettes d'eau preuve
donc que les feuilles de cet arbre
transpirer bien c'est pour cette raison
qu'à l'automne l'érable va perdre ses
feuilles pour économiser de l'eau de
l'eau qu'il ne pourrait pas puiser dans
le sol puisque très souvent je les vis
il est gelé par ailleurs en hiver à
cause du froid la feuille qui est plein
d'eau dont les cellules sont gorgés
d'eau gèlerait les cellules éclaterait
et la feuille moore est donc les
feuillus préfère perdre leurs feuilles à
l'automne
les conifères ne connaissent pas ce
genre de problèmes d'abord parce que les
aiguilles sont toutes fines et que la
surface de contact avec le froid est
très étroite ensuite quand on observe
ces aiguilles de très près on constate
qu'elles sont recouvertes d'une couche
cireuse une couche qui brille sous la
lumière cette couche ralenti la
transpiration enfin étant donné qu'elles
sont très étroites la neige ne peut pas
si accumulés pendant l'hiver et briser
les branches toutes ces raisons est la
plupart des conifères peuvent garder
leurs aiguilles pendant toute l'année y
compris en hiver la plupart il y a
toujours des exceptions le mélèze qui
lui perd ses aiguilles au début de
l'automne tout simplement parce que ces
aiguilles ne sont pas recouvertes de
cette petite couche sérieuse
[Musique]
vous voyez les habitations en bas ça
fait déjà une belle trotte alors marché
a priori ça semble très simple et
pourtant si l'on n'y prend pas garde on
peut très vite s'essouffle quelques
petits conseils marché à votre rythme le
plus régulier possible éviter
d'accélérer ou de ralentir
tiens un petit truc si vous êtes en
groupe tant que vous pouvez parler à
haute voix si tout va bien
pensez aussi à faire des pauses
régulières
pour vous réhydrater en plus quand on
retire son sac ça soulage le dos et les
épaules
il faut aussi profiter du paysage en
plus ici on voit très bien les
différents environnements que l'on peut
croiser en montagne les différents
milieux ici on parle des tâches en bas
il ya la vallée avec les villages et les
champs juste au dessus la forêt de
conifères qu'on vient de quitter encore
quelques marches et ce sont les alpages
où nous sommes on croise des troupeaux
et puis encore plus aux laitages nival
où il y a quasiment plus de végétation
là où à partir d'une certaine altitude
il n'ya les neiges éternelles
c'est très très beau
en fait peut-être pas traîné parce qu'on
a rendez vous avec les marmottes
allez c'est reparti
et je pénètre dans les cages alpin plus
précisément ce que l'on appelle la zone
de combats ici les végétaux livrent leur
dernier combat face aux éléments le vent
et le froid les arbres beaucoup moins
grand et la végétation pousse au ras du
sol à j'aperçois jean-paul notre ville
c'est lui qui à l'adresse des marmottes
et qui connaît aussi très bien et la
flore de ces haltes âge loge au port
qu'est-ce que tu prends en photo petit
parterre de crépy de doré fleurs
typiquement qu'on trouve en montagne
c'est sexy tôt on va aller vers la
petite gentiane qui est là l'ancien de
couleur pour donc beaucoup plus petite
que la grande gentiane jaune avec
laquelle on stade et d'alcool la
gentiane ponctué et si on regarde un
petit peu plus haut regarde on a une
grande pas nul un peu spécial ah oui des
petits points aux extrémités des pétales
dans l'après les campanules barbu tout
simplement et en contrebas un regard
diamé du petit fleuve tellement petit
nous casser du net je n appelle le
fraises casse lune et et regarde génie
ici la brunel alors ici à la montagne
évidemment on regarde les plantes on les
cueille pas on les laisse dans leur
milieu naturel là on a sous nos yeux un
insecte qui est en train de butiner
comme on est en altitude il y a moins
d'insectes tenant la vallée et donc pour
les attirer les plantes se sont habillés
de jolies couleurs
tiens j'ai me regarde au dessus de nous
la wii est ce que tu connais
[Musique]
harnik alors ça oui j'en ai dans mon
armoire à pharmacie sûrement
certainement toi donc c'est avec ce
genre de fleur qu'on fait donc les
fameuses poma dernier cas contre les
coups qu'est-ce qu'on utilise la feuille
et la fureur et ben ça fait mal ça fait
mal alors on a souvent le sentiment que
la montagne n'est qu'un espace de
loisirs or il s'y pratique tout un tas
d'autres activités économiques
l'exploitation du bois bien sûr et puis
l'élevage d'ailleurs nous avons devant
nous un petit groupe de vaches elle nous
a vu venir le petit conseil qu'on peut
donner c'est que étant donné que les
vaches ont les yeux sur les côtés quand
on s'en approche c'est d'éviter de leur
faire face pour les surprendre et plutôt
de les approcher par le flanc l'autre
petits conseils qu'on peut donner si une
vachette avec son veau il faut toujours
éviter de s'intercaler entre le petit et
la mer exactement les ondes jolie cloche
qu'on appelle ça alors la cloche qu'on
voit là qu'un sont quand même deux
casseroles 1 s'appelle le potin et
l'autre style de cloche qu'on peut voir
dans les alpages la cloche de la forme
de cloche qui est souvent graves et en
laiton un qu'un sont beaucoup plus fin
on l'appelle donc la clarine la clarine
où tout départ on leur met des cloches
pour les donc repérer dans l'alpage qui
est vaste ici qui est très large compte
qui peut voir pour savoir où elles sont
c'est vrai tout à l'heure on entendait
les cloches on ne les voyait me voyez
pas et en plus il faut imaginer aussi de
temps en temps ici et le brouillard
qu'est-ce qu'on rencontre comme raciste
alors rencontre particulièrement ici
donc la race abondants qui
particulier ajustements et sa robe
marron marron foncé et ses yeux si je
entouré de marrons et on appelle ceci
donc le dit justement les lunettes de
l'abondance sont les vins qui lie qui
protège encore luca deuxième du soleil
par rapport à sa tête bien blanche donc
moins de réverbération et l'autre race
qu'on peut voir dans nos secteurs là
c'est la race par in attarine qui est
plus clair donc ce l'abondance est la
même le le la tête tout marron clair et
des yeux magnifiques en forme d'amande
on a vraiment l'impression qu'elle se
maquille les il est charmant elle est
charmant ses petites lâchetés rinne avec
le relais en fabrique plusieurs fromages
l'abondance bien sûr bouffort agricole
et de la farine et hommes de montagne 1
alors si on trouve ces vaches dans les
alpages c'est pas par hasard elles sont
parfaitement adaptés au relief d'abord
elles ne sont pas très hautes elles sont
très agiles aussi ce qui leur permet de
grimper un peu partout elles ont un poil
très épais pour résister au froid fait
pas très chaud ici la nuit et résister
également au rayonnement solaire pendant
la journée et puis elles ont également
de petites mamelles pour éviter qu'elle
ne s'accroche au puy son rocher quand
elle quand bak dans ses reliefs on
continue c'est par où les marmottes je
crois que c'est par là bas allez je te
suis
[Musique]
c'est donc ici qu'habitent les marmottes
oui j'ai mis par ailleurs secteurs sont
en alerte si tu vois là elle nous
regarde
pas s'approcher un peu on va s'approcher
encore avancer doucement je sortais de
lunettes ouais donc tu vois jamila on a
des marmottes devant nous même si tu
prends tes jumelles jeunes tâches plus
clair tu vois oui je lâche et il faut
repérer des chamois ce sont des tâches
faux vin et les plus vieux sont un peu
plus clair donc les nouveaux repères il
connaît le déplacement humain il courait
alors que l'homme est également un de
ces prédateurs prédateur mais c'est très
curieux également chez moi toi lier ce
biais tout seul lui souvent ce sont les
mâles qui sont seuls là aussi c'est un
endroit où tu habitués à les voir oui on
vient très souvent les voir toi c'est
une réserve de chasse ici donc ne chasse
pas de chamois si on en voit très
couramment en général ce sont des
animaux qui sentent le matin au lever de
soleil ce que le but de la journée c'est
quand même d'aller manger c'est un
ruminant le chamois également c'est une
panse une fois que la pensée pleine il
va se coucher soir un abri ou sur un
rocher où il est bien l'ombre quand même
il n'aime pas trop trop les fortes
chaleurs le soleil donc il va se coucher
et rumine
[Musique]
j'espère que la balade vous a plu et
qu'elle va vous donner des idées pour
amener vos élèves en classe découverte
ici dans le chablais où vous retrouverez
jean-paul ou dans d'autres secteurs de
la région auvergne rhône-alpes que ce
soit la vanoise la maurienne la
tarentaise les bauges la chartreuse le
vercors les arts avis ou l'auvergne
poussé massif recèle de trésors sachez
que de mon côté ça a été un réel bonheur
de vous accompagner dans les différents
épisodes de cette classe grandeur nature
sur des sentiers qui en automne comme en
hiver ne sont battus que par le soleil
le vent et la neige que ce soit dans les
alpes ou en auvergne à bientôt et
n'oubliez pas la montagne c'est la
classe grandeur nature
[Applaudissements]